to the hospital breath my spirit back so
I got a ton of requests to play what I
actually want to play and this is
actually a game that I really love I
think this game is fantastic it's so
there's no point of me really telling
why I think this game is so great I
think I want to show you bros so this is
also part of the Humble Bundle so if you
want to pick up the game and support
charity support in developers right now
check the link in description I'm not
gonna finish the game but I want you
boys to enjoy some of it I [ __ ] love
the music - it's so awesome
and the trails gone under fun factory
droves pretty fast so I can never figure
out what to call this game Botanic ula
or botanical hour but 10 botannical cola
is a really bad word in Italian so I'm
just gonna call it botanic wallah
because y'all oh okay you can see my
mouse now another thing I really like
about the game is it just lets you play
you can figure it doesn't tell you a
click here or something you just click
around see what happens and that's
pretty much the quarter gameplay you and
stuff like that so there we go I'm a
[ __ ] genius
Oh Oh No the cloud of legs
oh no not my boss
Oh the book the Baldwin magic powers no
no I love this music by night and so
awesome
so mr. onion has a epiphany they need to
gather all these friends and plant the
seed wonderful I feel like I should name
all of them really weird names I don't
know if they have and it's particularly
okay I'll call it this one wait
is calling his friends wonderful okay so
he's carrying me okay got it okay so we
need a three of these feathers to make
him fly away because that makes sense
okay let's go over here um it's okay let
me let me figure out the nature
this one is faint this one is mushy
this one is Yoda
this one is Gandalf and this one is
Fanny my sister his name is fanny so
this is awkward but anyway let's keep
reading anyway the puzzles are like very
simple in the beginning in my opinion
and I never really got stuck while
playing this game I like my scenario and
when I was stuck all at oh okay that was
easy
good eye
there's a bit of quirkiness in this game
that I just love and especially the
music the music is really important for
me in a game and this game will just
like deliver this tiny tiny bits of
Awesomeness and you're like I want more
of that
but yeah nevertheless we gave birth to a
fine wine
oh my god pants this game is boring you
should put happy wheels
not today good good
not today our shed okay um there was a
while ago I play this honestly I don't
remember that much but I know you can
select like the character so let's lick
my sister Fanny Fanny can't do shed all
right you know what I'm gonna make this
my family so oh that's my my dad my mom
nice going dad and this will be my mom
uh Johanna my mom is just the best my
mother sister shed how can even all of
this game seriously
Yahoo skate makes me so happy
um okay let's keep going back to out of
the strategy I can count I don't think
we went over here so let's go bring it
we did not all right let's go up here
there's a leaf and there we go take it
better go for a [ __ ] okay who's gonna go
I guess I'll go I guess I call myself
Felix that makes sense right
Bravo me go pits um I'm gonna make my my
mama go oh good job pop up here let's go
okay Bravo
I don't remember the name of you I guess
you'll be mighty you'll see that see the
pretty one okay Fannie go Rama
no mama pills
Dania stare strikes again hey guys I'm
back it's the way I can say without
Sanya awkward yeah we did it
hello its face Danny go sir
fine
Oh
I got an achievement I didn't know that
I have that in school gets me a reason
to keep playing this by myself
I remember this point this is awesome
doing drugs with the family great family
activity I can highly not recommend it
if this game was mainstream
our news articles would write about it
and be like game support drug Oh what is
this oh yeah yeah they don't want to go
away they're just one more drugs oh ok
again good this will be this will be Ken
ok it's Tom oh no the cloudy thing
whatever
alright let's follow him I don't know
what the hell like I just talked all
right we have a king
Thank You kids oh man I'm just the best
the music is so awesome I know it's so
soft
that's all I can say about the awesome
it's a elleven we're floating on popup
it's um on remember oh okay this is a
tiny puzzle that yeah got a lot of the
sound effects alright it's actually my
favorite part here but I want to end it
because I want you bros to experience it
by yourself I know videos like this
probably get a lot of dislikes because
it's not funny or it's not scary but
it's nice sometimes to play a game that
I will show you bros a game that I
really love so I think you bros will
love it as well
remember you can kick it off right now
and support charity and support indie
developers I think that's really awesome
so if you're interested go and check it
out I'll be Rustom
Oh
and they get